♪ ♪
>> Tucker: HERE'S A QUESTION
WE KNOW THE ANSWER TO, WHAT IS
THE POINT OF AMERICAN INTEL
AGENCIES?
COULDN'T BE CLEARER IN THE LAW.
THE POINT OF AN AMERICAN INTEL
AGENCIES TO MONITOR WHAT HAPPENS
IN OTHER COUNTRIES AND THEN
REPORT BACK TO THE PRESIDENT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IF HE CAN MAKE BETTER DECISIONS
ABOUT U.S. FOREIGN POLICY.
MY FEAR THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE THE
CIA
, THE ONLY REASON.
THESE AGENCIES ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO SPY ON AMERICAN CITIZENS
BECAUSE THAT WOULD INVALIDATE
DEMOCRACY BUT THEY ARE DOING IT
ON A HUGE SCALE.
IN THEY ARE DOING IT ON DIRECT
ORDERS FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
NOT THE CONSPIRACY THEORY.
IT'S VERIFIED, IT'S TRUE.
NEW LEGISLATION FROM CONGRESS
SEEKS TO STOP THAT.
THIS LEGISLATION HAS BEEN
INTRODUCED BY CONGRESSMAN CHRIS
STEWART OF UTAH.
THE CONGRESSMAN JOINS US NOW TO
EXPLAIN.
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS.
THIS IS ILLEGAL, NOBODY SEEMS TO
CARE, WE SHOULD CARE.
WHAT WOULD YOUR LEGISLATION DO?
>> TO EMPHASIZE WHAT YOU'VE
ALREADY -- THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, NSA, CIA AND
OTHERS -- IS TO CONCENTRATE ON
FOREIGN THREATS, FOREIGN
TERRORISM, FOR NATION-STATES.
RUSSIA, CHINA, NORTH KOREA.
IT WAS NEVER EVER INTENDED THAT
THEY WOULD LOOK AT U.S. PRISONS
UNTIL THIS ADMINISTRATION COMES
ALONG AND SAYS THOSE OTHER
THREATS ARE IMPORTANT BUT THE
REAL THREAT WE ARE WORRIED ABOUT
IS DOMESTIC, VIOLENT EXTREMISM,
WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
BECAUSE THIS WHITE SUPREMACY
THREAT IS SO GREAT, WHICH BY THE
WAY IS NONSENSE, BUT BY THEIR
THINKING BECAUSE THIS IS SUCH A
GREAT THREAT, NOW WE NEED TO USE
THE POWER, THE TOOLS WE GIVE THE
NATIONAL SECURITY AGENCIES ARE
THE CIA, WE ARE ALLOWED TO APPLY
THEM ON U.S. PERSONS.
THAT IS WHY YOU HAVE A SITUATION
LIKE A YEAR AGO WHERE THE OFFICE
OF DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE, NOT THE FBI, NOT
HOMELAND SECURITY COMMITTEE DNI
USING THE TOOLS OF THE NATIONAL
COUNTERTERRORISM CENTER
PROVIDING BRIEFING TO CONGRESS
ON WHAT?
WHITE SUPREMACY.
BY DOMESTIC TERRORISM.
IT SHOULD ENRAGE AMERICANS THAT
THEY WOULD THINK THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO USE THIS AWESOME
POWER.
IF YOU THINK YOU WANT TO BUILD
AN AMERICAN KGB, IF YOU THINK
THAT IS A GOOD IDEA, THEN KEEP
GOING DOWN THIS ROAD.
BUT IF YOU THINK IT'S A
HORRIBLE, FEARSOME IDEA, THEN
PLEASE WORK WITH ME.
I'M TALKING TO MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, PLEASE WORK WITH ME TO
TRY TO STOP IT.
>> Tucker: THEY'VE SPIED ON
THIS SHOW, THEY'VE ADMITTED IT.
I'VE SPOKEN WITH TWO
CONGRESSPEOPLE WHOSE JOB IT IS
WHO TOLD ME DIRECTLY THEY WERE
BEING SPIED ON BY THE INTEL
AGENCIES AND THEY DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
I WONDER HOW MANY CONGRESSPEOPLE
ARE TOO INTIMIDATED TO PUSH BACK
ON THE PARIS OF THESE AGENCIES?
>> WELL I GUESS WE ARE GOING TO
FIND OUT.
IT'S NOT JUST THE PRESS, WE KNOW
THAT BRENT AND LIED ABOUT IT
WHEN THEY WERE SPYING ON MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE.
FOR HEAVEN'S SAKE, IF THE LAST
FOUR OR FIVE YEARS HAVE TAUGHT
US ANYTHING IT HAS SURELY TAUGHT
US THAT SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE
FBI AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WERE CLEARLY DECEPTIVE TO
CONGRESS, DECEPTIVE TO THE FISA
COURTS, DECEPTIVE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND ONCE AGAIN
THEY WANT TO INCREASE THAT
ABILITY, ENHANCE THAT ABILITY BY
DRAWING IN THESE OTHER AGENCIES.
ONCE AGAIN, THERE'S NO REASON
FOR IT, NO NEED FOR IT.
THERE IS ENOUGH TERROR THREATS
AND OTHER THREATS FOR THEM, IT'S
NOT LIKE THEY'VE GOT EXTRA
BANDWIDTH LIKE THEY DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO.
AND VERY CLEARLY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND FBI, THAT IS
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY.
NOT THE CIA, NOT THE NSA.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY, SO NICELY
PUT.
WE ARE ROOTING F